[Music]
kayla's kicking us off in billings
montana kayla welcome to the ramsay show
hi how are you guys we're so great how
can we help today
good thank you um so
my question is um my husband and i moved
across the country
recently and i am unhappy here um and
i'm just wondering
at what point do you put forth mental
health and caring for that versus
finances and putting yourself in a bind
or losing money on our house
oh
often when you back yourself into a
corner and give yourself one of two
cryptic options
um there's something else going on tell
me what else is going on here
um okay so
oh gosh i don't know i
i'm just very depressed where we live
now um
where are you what what is it about this
environment this world are you missing
your friends from your old place your
whole community are you not plugging in
did you have a bad experience what is it
yeah a couple couple of things um we are
very far from our family
um it kind of feels isolating um and the
weather here is a little rougher than i
prefer like winters are very long and
seasonal depression i feel like is a
real thing it's a super real thing yeah
yeah and so um
it's just hard and
just not as
much to do as or the things that i enjoy
doing
um we had a home before and so i missed
that home in that area and that climate
and
people coming to visit us and we have a
house now but nobody comes to visit
because we're very far away um or if
they do it's very rare so why did you
guys move stuff like that why'd you move
why um he works he's a truck driver he
works for fedex and if we transferred he
the pay was a lot higher
so he went from being a city driver um
in tennessee and then we transferred out
west where he was a road driver and they
get paid quite a bit more
um
so we could always transfer back um but
they aren't hiring at the moment for
road or city so
we're just i'm just here trying to
figure out what to do how many years ago
how long have you lived there
um we've been here a year but we've been
out west two years okay
um
i had a very similar experience when i
moved from texas where i had my
community my friends and my family and
to
tennessee to nashville into what was a
great job as it was a
much
it's a much more significant paying job
it was an incredible group of people i
got to work with but i was lonely i was
missing people
and
i
liked doing these things and i wasn't
able to do those things here because now
i'm in the city i've got a reverse of
what you experienced
and ultimately my wife and i had to sit
down and say okay um we're gonna go all
in on making this our home
and it was a completely different
identity shift and she actually went way
faster than i did she went made friends
got connected started going to coffee
with people and that's not her nature
it's not my nature
and um i had to i've told some stories
on air about inviting people to my house
and be like so this is super weird but
will you be my friend um we go hang out
and when someone would invite me that i
didn't know that well to watch the
fights i said yes every time and i've
come like i'm i'm
my our family goal now a year a few
years after that
time
is this is it
like my my goal and hope in life is to
die in tennessee okay this became my
home but it took some high
intentionality in our part so here's my
challenge to you number one don't frame
this as money or mental health that's
not a fair framing of this
it's not hey you want to be rich and
crazy and depressed that's not really
what's happening here what's happening
here is hey we made a decision together
that we this is going to be a
significant increase in pay for us we're
going to be able to change some things
of our lives that we thought was going
to be great and maybe we missed the mark
and that's okay we tried it out two
years three years cool let's get back on
the transfer list and see if when that
happens until then we are not going to
voluntarily choose misery
i'm not going to choose to be miserable
waiting for this thing that may or may
not happen in 2 months 5 months 2 years
10 years
choose the things that are going to make
you joyful in the meantime that may mean
that we need to add to our budget plane
tickets because we thought we could see
family once a year i want to see them
three and that's just gonna be a thing
that we're gonna do that's a little bit
different um i am not big on going to
coffee with with the gals i'm going to
coffee with the gals i'm gonna make that
a part of my life you see what i'm
saying go all in where you are
and
if you go all in where you are and you
come back and you say hey i want to go
back to tennessee and you end up back
tennessee and kentucky or north carolina
whatever nobody failed anything nobody
lost anything we thought this was going
to be the right thing for us what i
found was
oh man i just missed my family and
friends and that's a completely normal
thing you're supposed to be sad when you
miss your family and friends and now my
new life adventure was finding new
people to do life with and i have you
see what i'm saying
i see yeah i see more of the effort well
it's not no see there you go okay i'm
just not doing enough no no no no
not like that
not like that here's what i'm saying
um
it's
it's completely normal to feel you feel
right now
okay
and moving forward you have a choice do
i want to continue this
do i want to continue just to be here
and be sad or do i want to do something
differently not do more don't do
something different
and what you're doing right now is is
you've been
i mean you've been healing right you
made a big major move now we're healing
now we're going to figure out something
that's new and let's set a time limit
with my husband when he's home let's say
let's put a pin on the calendar at six
months let's just check back in with
each other at six months and see how
we're doing and i'm gonna go all in you
go all in we're gonna make this thing
work we're gonna choose to have fun out
here even though i'm not really a hiker
or a i don't fly fish i don't know what
you do in montana um but normally i
wanted to
i'm more of a pedal tavern gal there in
downtown nashville and there's no pedal
taverns out here and i don't know i'm
losing right i'm being
i'm being rude but
um
decide to go all in there and then put
something on the calendar and it gives
you some peace right this isn't a
forever thing and this isn't a cast into
the ocean and if you are struggling
if you are feeling depression in a way
that i don't want to get out of bed i
don't like anybody um the the
i i've just i i don't have joy
please call somebody okay
yeah please go visit a counselor okay
and yes seasonal depression is very very
very real
very real um there's all kinds of lights
you can get there's all kinds of
interventions you can do with lighting
on your house and activities you can do
to help with the
lights that is a very real thing
and winter is coming right so be ready
for that as it heads your way yeah
that's huge yeah when i moved to
nashville john from mobile which i had
moved from boston you just reset and i
had to go all right i'm gonna get
plugged into my local church i made some
great friends there i started here at
ramsey solutions i knew no one and now
they're some of my best friends here to
my best community via the church and
work and i love it and i can't ever
imagine going back to boston but that
takes a lot of time and intentionality
and that's all we're asking for and some
awkwardness and some failure it's a part
of it and you're a of awkward king of
awkward john has mastered it